salut vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui on
va parler d'une expérience avec booba
est qui qui est alors ici le seul
l'octogone qui les oppose c'est celui
qui à l'intérieur du cerveau et vous
allez voir que les effets dessus sont
surprenants alors qu' à booba qui a
cliqué loïc je verrai mais qui est booba
mais qui est qui qui découvrons le
ensemble comme vous pouvez le constater
nous sommes dans des conditions un peu
particulières parce que je joue dans un
théâtre pour tourner les vidéos en gros
ce tournage et en live avec plus de 500
personnes qui sont connectés il ya
quelques unes des personnes qui seront
avec moi dans les écrans qui sont autour
de moi et donc à une partie de la vidéo
que je tourne avant cette connexion et
quand je voudrais faire les tests pour
qui et booba qui est qui qui ce sera dès
que la vie de comprendre avant de vous
faire le grand test booba qui qui il
faut un peu parler d'où ça vient alors
l'effet booba qui à la base ces deux
dessins ont étudié laurent cohen et
nathan p faire smadja de l'institut du
cerveau et de la moelle épinière
mais à la base c'est connu depuis très
longtemps parce que c'est le psychologue
qui était germaneau américano en gros un
peu des états unis un peu de l'allemagne
et qui s'appelle wolf gang kohler je
suis pas sûr de bien le dire donc je
veux dire qu'une seule fois
il a étudié ça et il en a parlé dès 1929
maintenant avant de vous en parler un
peu plus il nous faut réaliser eux grand
test le coi loïc le grand le grand quoi
le grand test donc là à l'écran vous
avez deux images qui sont apparues
regardez bien ces deux images laquelle
et booba et laquelle est qui qui vous
pouvez mettre votre réponse dans les
commentaires si vous voulez ce serait
même plutôt cool parce qu'il ya plus
l'option de sondage et pour ma part je
vais en profiter d'avoir des personnes
en direct en temps dans cette vidéo dans
le théâtre pour leur poser la question
des pays bas qui je peux pas vous
expliquer ce que c'est avant nous faire
le test le test il date de 1929 je crois
et l'idée c'est de savoir qui et booba
est qui et qui
c'est pour ma chaîne pour enfants devant
je vous demander de penser à la première
réponse qui conviendra dans votre tête
et après de ne plus en changer
je vous faire voir deux dessins ces deux
dessins il faut qu'ils à un nom et dans
votre tête vous allez vous dire qui et
booba et qui est qui qui parmi cette
liste
sarr endocrinologue sérieux confessé
restent inquiets mais gardez la réponse
pour vous et je vous demanderai à près
de lever la main d'accord
donc voici les deux dessins est ce que
vous les voyez correctement ou pas l'un
de ces deux dessins s'appelle booba
l'autre s'appelle kick déterminé dans
votre esprit qui s'appelle booba et qui
s'appelle qui pue ça doit être fait
maintenant levé la main les personnes
qui pensent que ce dessin là c'est booba
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
donc c'est ce personnage qu'est ce ce
personnes baisser les mains s'il vous
plaît c'est excellent comme on peut le
constater la majorité des personnes ont
attribué le nom booba aux formes qui
était plutôt arrondies et le nom kiki
aux formes qui était plutôt en arrêt
tout en pointe en trucs qui font un pied
pions en vue leur merci la grande
question maintenant qui se pose c'est
pourquoi ça nous fait ça alors la
première hypothèse qui semble être la
bonne c'est que les êtres humains
partageraient une forme de synesthésie
commune
si vous savez pas vraiment ce que c'est
la synesthésie j'en ai fait une vidéo
que je mettrai dans la description mais
en gros il y en a 180 de formes
différentes
il ya par exemple la synesthésie qui
fait que certaines personnes attribuent
un jour de la semaine à une couleur mais
ce n'est pas un choix qu'ils ont fait
sciemment qu'ils ont décidé depuis
qu'ils sont petits tel jour de la
semaine le rappel par exemple bleu ou le
rouge ou le violet ou des fois des
nuances aussi dans les couleurs et bien
on aurait une forme de synesthésie
commune toute l'humanité entière
en 2001 le test que nous venons de faire
avait été réalisé de nouveau par ces
deux personnes dont je ne prononcerai
pas non je laisse plutôt l'oit l'écrire
de ces lettres magnifique merci beaucoup
ils ont refait l'expérience de couleurs
et 95% des gens ont attribué le nom
booba aux formes arrondies
c'est pas du hasard c'est hyper
significatif qui est le plus intéressant
dans cette expérience c'est que ça avait
été fait en partie avec des gens qui
habitaient aux états unis dont qui par
les américains est en partie avec des
gens qui habitent et en inde
oui ça alors parce qu'il parlait le
tamil tu perds tu vas tu parles de ta
mine oui c'est vrai dis moi un mot bravo
mieux que ça même des enfants de moins
de 2 ans ou d'à peine deux ans ont
attribué le nom booba aux formes
arrondies alors qu'ils savent même pas
écrire les faits booba kiki c'est une
correspondance non arbitraire entre la
forme d'un objet et le son qu'on lui
associe en 2015 une autre étude de sea
doo et pixman pourquoi les chercheurs et
les psychologues qui s'appelle pas juste
tous jean-jacques quand même beaucoup
plus simple direct jean jacques un
jean-jacques 2 bon bref ils ont refait
l'étude et on s'est aperçu que même avec
d'autres mots et d'autres prénoms ont
retrouvé à peu près d
la même procédure c'est à dire que les
gens attribuent plutôt le prénom molly à
quelqu'un qui a un visage plutôt
arrondies et le prénom kate à quelqu'un
qui a des traits plus anguleux
d'ailleurs dans ces études on voit qu'il
ya une extension qui est faite parce que
les personnes qui ont des visages
arrondi on leur prête comme ça d'une
manière spontanée des intentions plus
douce on pense que ce sont des personnes
plutôt calme plutôt gentil et c'est
alors que les personnes qui ont le
visage plus anguleux on se dit que ce
sont des personnes un peu plus nerveuse
et depuis on a découvert qu'il existe
d'autres synesthésie automatique entre
des sondés couleurs des choses comme ça
déforme
par exemple quand vous entendez un son
aigu si je vous mettais la un panel de
couleurs vous attribue riez plutôt ce
sens est due à une couleur claire
une couleur pastel où vivent ou très
claire alors que les sons plutôt grave
notre cerveau les attribue plutôt à des
couleurs sombres et je sais que vous
savez que vous dites
et oui c'est vrai que si j'entends à son
grave jeu plutôt imaginer l'ambiance un
peu dark appel mais pourquoi le prénom
saint jacques
oui lui à quelques couleurs alors à la
couleur jaune cdu jeunes jaune donne ça
va beaucoup plus loin que ça puisque
même maintenant les marques intègre ça
dans la réflexion marketing pour nommer
le produit pour donner la forme du
produit ou la forme du logo qui va y
avoir sur le produit c'est des vrais
études qui sont faites pour envoyer des
signaux psychologique puisqu'on sait que
ça marche en automatisme alors c'est
parfois fait consciemment et déploie sur
moins consciemment mais sur ce qu'on
veut nous faire penser aux ressentir
comme sentiment sur des personnages dans
les films si vous voyez un personnage
comme dark vador vous allez voir que son
casque est rempli de triangle et
d'angles un petit peu partout si vous
regardez la sorcière maléfice qui
représente donc le mal est bien tout est
très anguleux dans son personnage
alors que si vous voyez un personnage
comme raf dans le monde de ralph il est
tout arrondi c'est censé être un méchant
dans le jeu et pourtant on est
bienveillant envers lui et c'est vrai
que c'est le héros qu'il est plutôt cool
au final on a ça aussi dans le logo de
disney ça a été réfléchie on a trois
cercles c'est le plus arrondies possible
c'est le plus beau
possible on pourrait dire ça et il ya
aussi une géométrie intermédiaire dans
les films qui est plutôt celle du carré
seignard on dit li anguleux en mode
triangle épique
on pourrait avoir par exemple des faux
méchant tels que le vieil homme qui a
dans le film où le dessin animé du moins
là haut on sait que c'est pas un vrai
méchant c'est plutôt un gentil qui rôle
qu'y joue le rôle d'un faux méchant et
bien lui il est entre les deux donc on
voit bien qu'on utilise ça mais j'ai
plein d'exemples à vous donner avant
d'arriver aux marques reprenons quelques
exemples cinématographique l'ours dans
le livre de la jungle
c'est clairement un booba dans
ratatouille rémy c'est un bon bah alors
que le critique qui vient manger dans
son restaurant c'est clairement un kiki
en termes de très colère dans le dessin
animé vice versa c'est un kiki alors que
tristesse c'est un bon bain mais quand
je vous dis que les marques ont
travaillé dessus
il ya d'abord les chercheurs qui ont
travaillé dessus par exemple des
chercheurs qui ont demandé à des
participants volontaires d'écouté des
centres tels que ketty lujo booba qui
qui est d'imaginer dans leur tête
à quelle forme ces sons pour être
associée est ce que ce serait une forme
arrondie ou une forme avec des petits
pics des petits angles des petits trucs
pointus comme ça donc il n'y a pas de
formes de référence il avait un bouton
pour appuyer 6 7 euros ou pointu
évidemment vous connaissez déjà les
résultats de cette expérience et c'est
sur ce genre de choses que les marques
ont réfléchi pour créer leur nom de
marque
voici un logo que vous connaissez bien
google et google ça renvoie à dubout bas
et du coup c'est un truc cool
bienveillant plutôt sympathique une
marque comme nike nike ça renvoie à un
kiki et qui tissent et volontaire c'est
agressive ces combattants ça relève des
défis ça gagne des trophées ça arrive
promis
chupa chups chupa chups ça vous fait
penser aux sucettes pour enfants donc
aux enfants mais de base chupa chups on
est sûr de l'ultra douba c'est quelque
chose on ne sait pas pourquoi et
pourtant ce sont ça nous rappelle déjà
l'enfance aussi peut-être parce qu'on a
le chou qui se répète deux fois mais
chupa chups on est sur du booba enfantin
regardez cette belle voiture cette belle
voiture c'est une jaguar et jaguar c'est
plutôt un carré parce que dans la
prononciation jaguar on sait que c'est
pas vraiment du goût a s'est pas
vraiment du chi chi pourtant il ya un
truc entre les deux et c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'on a ce sentiment de
performance et de sécurité et de confort
en même temps quand on voit une jaguar
alors que des marquises agressif comme
celle-ci kärcher bon c'est que voilà ça
envoie là on est sur du gros qui qui qui
nettoie d'isoler jamais cette phrase
s'il vous plaît de cette vidéo elle se
regarde dans son entier et même certains
mots hasard ou pas ont été développés
avec des connotations émotionnel
positives ou négatives
regardez le dark web dans dark web on a
dark et dark c'est un mot qui fait peur
d'eux par sa signification
mais il a aussi un son de kiki
clairement dans explosion on a une salle
intérieure lors ce x ça peut être
considéré comme un point avec quatre
choses qui partait qui explose de quatre
côtés de différence ce point qui expose
des quatre côtés qui donne cette image
d'explosion on va le retrouver dans
excitation exquise galaxie box
explorateur des choses ou à chaque fois
ils énergie part de plusieurs côtés en
même temps alors qu'un mot comme maman
même s'il n'a pas été inventé par une
marque dans notre langage spontanément
on a choisi ce mot là pour être encore
plus booba que le mot mère en fait c'est
ce c'est ce mot d'affection ultime et
bien c'est maman est là on sait
clairement que c'est un mois la buba là
on est en train de dériver un petit peu
vers autre chose ça s'appelle le langage
des oiseaux
si ça vous dit je vous ferai une vidéo
là dessus un jour vous me dites dans les
commentaires si vous voulez une vidéo là
dessus mais pour le moment on s'éloigne
rétro du concept booba qui guide cette
vidéo si vous ne connaissez pas je
m'appelle fabien olicard vous pouvez
vous abonner à cette chaîne c'est
gratuit activer la cloche pour voir la
prochaine vidéo n'hésitez pas à liker si
vous avez aimé cette vidéo est là je
vous en mets deux autres celle ci c'est
sur l'effet dorian gray qui montre qu'on
a un peu le visage de notre prénom
scientifiquement c'est un peu bizarre
regarder ça et là je vous en mets une
eau
je vais vous m c'est une vidéo pour se
débloquer une compétence dans le cerveau
en gros vous regardez cette vidéo et à
la fin vous savez faire quelque chose
d'étrange à très bientôt ciao